hey there here we are again with yet
another movie retrospective yes a good
one
although this isn't so much a
retrospective because this is actually a
very recent maybe it only came out in
2018 this was another one that was sent
to us by our friend and patron Sophie
she also sent a Dracula
told this is the 2018 movie upgrade yeah
and she said she said it to us on
blu-ray it was good movie I was
surprised with it I did not realize when
we were watching it that it was written
then directed by Lee one L or one L he's
the guy that did he wrote SAW and
insidious and all those James Wan movies
so I didn't realize that this was a
movie I think that guy and it's but and
it's done by a Blum house you know the
Jason's long I didn't seesaw or
insidious you didn't see no you didn't
seesaw
how do you have not seen saw I thought
everybody's I didn't see most of the
sequels but I first heard those kind of
like what movies it's just kind of like
a bunch of torture porn what they go it
is but I think they got a lot more
torture porn II later I liked any of
that kinda stuff
the first well the first one is actually
a pretty good it's got a like a lot of
gore but it's a pretty good like
psychological this one was good though
this one was more like a sci-fi action
adventure yeah
pretty neat about a guy who gets in a
bad car wreck and a multi-billionaire
tech giant inserts this damn computer
chip into his broken spinal column
yeah and then which kind of reanimates
him so they can move again but it's got
a cited there guy that's got like an
added side benefit it's like an AI yeah
they could talk to him and it can do all
this stuff
it could access the end basically turns
him into a superhero yeah it was it was
kind of like that it's like I've seen it
compared to because it actually I think
it premiered at the South by Southwest
festival which a lot of kind of horror
and indie films do and it got a pretty
good response there and people like
compared it to sort of like Death Wish
and the Six Million Dollar Man and like
put together
um it got like really good reviews and
they actually when they release it in
the theaters it made I think they were
only expecting it to make like 2 million
because I don't think it cost that much
to make but it actually ended up making
like twice as much I think it often made
almost 5 million this is a testament to
the kind of deal where sometimes less is
more
yeah no reason if you ask me there's no
reason to make some of these really
giant huge big budget blockbusters yeah
I think it's kind of a waste of money I
could tell that same story with all that
stuff and make it as a school like this
yeah this kind of had the feeling in a
certain way of an old eighties movie but
it did it was placed very much like that
yeah like an old Arnold Schwarzenegger
movie or but like a good one yeah oh
yeah because Arnie had some misses too
but this one was like one that was a hit
and but it did it didn't look like 80s
visually it was like up-to-date the
visuals are very up-to-date the future
was very believable was kind of like
sleek and streamlined it wasn't over
complicated just for the real kind of
modernistic looking decor sparse decor
inside the houses self-driving cars that
didn't even really have windows but they
would kind of make like windows if he
needed him remember dreams were kind of
like to waste green did it it didn't say
what year this was supposed to be right
I can't don't think it ever really
specified exactly what year was it
didn't look like it looked futuristic
but it not real like crazy future no it
looked like maybe 20-30 years in the
future yeah something like that and it
didn't show any technology that doesn't
already exist
it shows Excel technology that does
exist yeah just as very evolved yeah
yeah and it works real well you know
like drones that are little and they fly
and they do all the cool [ __ ] and they
can even hijack self-driving cars or
that was really cool
yeah hacking into self-driving cars and
how a person could become a cyborg and
the cyborg kind of had automatic
self-defense programs so you as a person
don't even have any skills but the your
body's moving and you're defending
yourself you just have to see the movie
to see
I'm talking about it's it's cool yeah
because he's um the guy that's in it
slogan Marshall green and he plays a guy
named great race and uh which I kind of
love that name I'm like it doesn't
really sound like a name it sounds like
they're you know what I mean
like a great race yes yeah yeah you can
tell it's their turn to refer to but
yeah so at the beginning I mean he's in
the self-driving car with his wife it
gets you know and it wrecks getting
hijacked by and it gets hijacked right
yeah yeah back into some thieves hack
into it yeah at least I guess they were
thieves not really worthy weren't they
terrorists more like terrorists yeah and
I think they come back into the movie a
car on a bike they reappear later
there's more to that story
yeah well there was a reason why that
why that happened like why his car got
hijacked why his wife got killed why I
mean so he is basically rendered a
quadriplegic and like I said he knows
it's actually does he know it's I think
his wife knows this guy who's like a
tech billionaire I've only seen this
movie once yeah and I want to see it
again they're not every little detail
stuck with me yeah it was just really
cool like to see it again
you know I couldn't recommend the movie
just on the back of one viewing yeah it
was it was it was a movie that packs a
lot of punch for being a low-budget
movie yeah a really well-done low-budget
movie yeah yeah I really liked it it's
like yes so he's a quadriplegic and he
ends up getting he gets talked into like
by this tech billionaire he's like hey
do you want to try out my it's called
stem and he's like it'll like make it so
that you can walk again but the caveat
being do you remember that couldn't tell
him you can't tell anybody so he still
has to pretend like he's a quadriplegic
even though he has this implant that a
lot that actually gives him like
super-strength nowadays nowadays it
wouldn't matter because they they passed
that what is it right to try bill where
you have a right to become a guinea pig
I don't think it was legal in this movie
for him to volunteer himself as a guinea
pig that's why
to keep us quiet that's how I understood
it I'm not sure if that's why because I
think that maybe the billionaire had
other motives okay and that maybe he
just didn't want anyone to know because
based on my memory I thought that that
that he told him to keep it quiet
because it wasn't quite legal that it
hadn't been approved yeah maybe that's
what it was
like I said I want to see it yeah but
like I said we watched it once but you
know sometimes for these we like to see
them a bunch of times
yeah but some wants it was good though
it reminded me a little bit I mean not
hugely but it but in the sense that the
implant is like you said as artificial
intelligence and it actually it
essentially becomes like another
personality like inside his brain like
it here it yeah it's like it talks to
him and nobody else can hear it and if
he chooses to he can give the AI control
over his body um you know like if he's
fighting a guy and he can just say you
know okay you take over and the AI will
take over and just beat the [ __ ] out of
the guy without him without gray having
to do anything or come up with plants
that he couldn't have thought he
couldn't even thought of yes another
person like living in his head yeah he
was coming to attack by all these
basically superior enemies and you know
the AI program it was called stem right
isn't call himself stem just start
saying if you want I can take care of
this no problem
yeah and it's Easter you know and stem
starts going through the damn Internet
through wireless services and starts
hacking computers and doing cool [ __ ]
and fighting it's quite cool you know I
mean he kind of ended up with almost
kind of like super hero super hero or
godlike powers yeah through this really
yeah through this badass AI program that
was not part of him yeah and and managed
his body for him it was a cool concept
it kind of what I was gonna say that
like in the sense that he had this other
being like talking to him in his head it
kind of reminded me of venom and yeah in
a way as funny is that the fighting
skills of this thing it wasn't this
fluid matron
the times that did the things just real
clunky but super efficient and robot
yeah yeah it looks [ __ ] it looks
[ __ ] [ __ ] I won't work
I liked that about yeah because like I
said it's it's not like it made you know
like it wasn't like Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon hurt okay or if you like
fly into being all grace no just turning
like t1 like Terminator watch yeah just
yeah but it didn't look dumb and I look
realistic it looks really cool because
that career was just the computer was
just defending itself or defending the
body in the most efficient way the most
efficient way is not all that yeah it
was calculating like how to do it in the
most efficient fat yeah and like with
the least amount of motion and yeah the
least you know that amount of effort
right doing that yeah but yeah so so as
it turns out is like this is actually
like a really new movie so and I'm
assuming a lot of people have not seen
it so I don't really want to spoil it
too much but yeah as you know since it's
a dystopian sci-fi type movie or
whatever you know that [ __ ] is gonna go
horribly horribly wrong and that there
was like some there was like a grand
plan like why he got that particular
implant and you know what happened with
all the with the accident and everything
with his wife getting killed and all
this other kind of stuff and like ice I
can't even I can't remember exactly why
I sort of remember exactly why I like
the billionaire wanted that wanted him
to have that implant in particular but I
got forgot but I can't remember which I
guess is good because then I can't spoil
it the movie is the movies gonna be is
is gonna be very rewatchable as soon as
I got done seeing it I wanted to see it
again but we have a really tight
schedule yeah so we'll have to see it
again soon pick up it looks it remember
the story being basically a setup for a
series yeah so that there were gonna be
more stories about it it struck me as a
movie very similar to one of my favorite
Arnold Schwarzenegger movies the sixth
day it kind of felt and looked in
certain ways like that but
bring in some of the matrix and Blade
Runner and maybe like Terminator 1 or
maybe like Robocop
it's just weird it's just we get to see
yourself and it had like I liked also
yeah it had a little bit of like humor
in it too my god zany humor like some
kind of like dark humor and visually it
kind of looked like it kind of looked
like [ __ ] what's the one about the the
assassin with Kenny Reeves the one
that's the part three is coming out John
wick John wick it was lit kind of like a
John wick yeah like the high
dramatically yeah kinda how it looked
but that mixed with like almost horse
nickers a 6-day t1 Robocop Blade Runner
kind of come together I just liked it
good movie and I like to that you
mentioned you know you mentioned Blade
Runner and you mentioned Terminator and
stuff like that because because I have
seen like some reviews of this movie
that compared it to like a John
Carpenter movie yeah James Cameron type
movie yeah you know from the 80s not
like I said it doesn't look like
something from the 80s but in the haste
sort of like that it has like that same
kind of tone has that same kind of feel
it yes like a John wick film really yeah
it did actually visually it did kind of
like a job job not quite as noticeable
Walker colorful yeah it had that same
palette though yeah and it was shot kind
of like that but imagine a John wick
film in the future yeah you know I mean
it's not happening in cathedrals in
underground bars and secret societies as
soon as the future yeah I'm excited
about that about the new John Waite
coming out yeah but actually um as it
turned out like I said this this movie
actually got really like pretty decent
reviews made more money than they
thought it was going to make like I said
not a huge amount but they hadn't spent
a huge amount on it according to the
Wikipedia page it was blum house this
was their second biggest opening the
first biggest was the darkness which I
even saying I think that was a remake
was only one about the little creatures
in it only made 5 million yeah
damn that's a very small amount how much
did it is but I don't know how much that
much but they were they were only
expecting it to make 3 million it
doesn't feel like a cheap movie at all
it really doesn't know I believe movie
yeah I wouldn't have well that's
something I was reading um I didn't even
remember where I was reading it the
other day but I was I was reading the
other day this article about the best
sci-fi movies that don't have any
special effects in them like this one
definitely does but it just goes to show
that you don't need didn't rely on a
gigantic budget you don't need like all
the CGI and stuff like that if you have
a good idea and you have good actors and
you know what you're doing and a good
story and it's and yeah he's right it's
good then you can make sci-fi without
and people will not notice that there's
not like big monsters and you know
computer-generated what's it's like
fooling around everywhere and I'm not
you know I'm not [ __ ] on movies that
do have that because there are some like
that that are good but you don't need
that and so I think that that's another
thing you know that this kind of movie
demonstrates is that yes it has some
special effects in it but it's not
dependent on it's not dependent on them
it's not like this big like ooh
whiz-bang feature and it's just like it
doesn't have let's create [ __ ] in it
it's just a good story and it has like
some humor and it has a lot of action in
it you know it's just like a good yeah
movie that didn't have cost a lot of
money to make some of these blockbusters
nowadays that you know cost a hundred
billion dollar swings when you watch
them it's almost kind of like you're on
a visual ride at Disneyland or Disney
World
yeah they're not really movie like yeah
it's just like aspected no like a
spectacle or ride that you're on yeah
and you know sometimes that's good
sometimes that works sometimes it does
it yeah it depends on what you want this
particular movie is just for me it's
like a new brand new high-tech
old-school 80s sci-fi adventure action
movie yeah
with with modern sensibilities yeah that
kind of looks like John wick in the
future yeah yeah I would say that's a
good way that's how I'm gonna describe
it and like I said I thought it was
interesting too when I kind of mean you
know I watched the movie and like I was
looking at the credits and stuff but I
guess I didn't realize that Leigh
Whannell had done this and this might
I'm not really sure this might be his
only sci-fi movie because usually he
does horror one of the things I liked
about it is that some lot of futuristic
movies they they make the mistake of
trying to make the future look to future
is he yeah pack too much [ __ ] in a room
yeah like they did that a lot in that in
the eighties too many goddamn screens
yeah too many screens everywhere in this
movie everything looks some places look
broken-down and nasty if that's what if
that's you know like the bar was the
dive bars are always gonna look like
that yeah
but the houses were nice and simplistic
just wood floors brick and stone walls
lots of glass and chrome but not a lot
of crazy appliances because technology
taking care of all the appliances yeah
you know so you know look like the
[ __ ] Jetsons it didn't look like the
future from Back to the Future - yeah
that was that future was [ __ ] crazy
you know that was the future as
envisioned - by somebody in the 80s on
crack yeah yeah remember when everybody
had their own fax machines there was
every room there was a fax machine
so future is dead yeah I do I love still
love that movie but yeah and the fruit
comes down from the ceiling
yeah there's no internet there's just
more screens yeah yeah wasn't there in
Back to the Future 2 didn't have the
same where she put that little bitty
pizza in the man it seems like this is a
dehydrated pizza I guess so but that's
the thing it's like I always felt like
like I said and we've had this
discussion before but I was always like
if I you know if I had millions of
dollars to make a movie one I probably
wouldn't make a sci-fi cuz I'm her
person but if you're gonna make a sci-fi
I feel like that's one of the hardest
honors to make cuz is that it dates
yeah easily I mean the only reason that
movies like Blade Runner and stuff like
that still look good now is because they
didn't try to make it look futuristic
necessarily they actually went back to
like a newer type of look yeah basically
what Gattaca did Gattaca yeah it looked
like a real clean version of the 50s the
car so kind of yeah and everybody wore
suits and everything was real kind of
clean and minimalist yeah more they even
see much technology and I think and that
worked that is the safe way to go it's
like don't try to like extrapolate that
all these crazy gadgets we're gonna have
you know like again in Back to the
Future to where he has the [ __ ]
jackets and shoes that let you blow them
like fit yourself to your body
Jacket is dry yeah
oaky technology than the hoverboard
which everybody wants one of those but
it's like yeah other than that it's just
they really do not call it the jaws 15
the damage yeah the shark still looks
fake yeah yeah and it looks
significantly shitty it looks Baker in
the future yeah it really did so but but
this is one that like you said it does
it right it doesn't do anything too
crazy it's like you know yeah they have
self-driving cars and stuff like that
but we have those it's not like some big
crazy thing they didn't try to go
overboard with it the houses just like
you said they look very sleek there's
not a Gattaca now yeah or something like
that it's you know there's not like a
bunch of buzzing yeah crap everywhere
like chars intimate ography future way
everything was set up account to me it
look like like a John wick movie yeah
but yeah it had like a really cool look
to it and yeah it's definitely a movie I
would recommend yeah like sighs I want
to see it again that we're talking about
it want to watch it again yeah who's
gonna movie and again thank you so
basically for sending us that if you're
sending us Dracula and told to
definitely recommend movies yes Dracula
untold and great yes check it out all
right that'll do it for our review of
upgrade from 2018 remember if you liked
the show like share subscribe on all
your social media if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon
Paige patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or go to our blog 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress comm and there's a
button in the sidebar to a PayPal
account if you'd like to give a one-time
donation remember that our regular
episodes of 13 o'clock which are usually
paranormal or true crime or whatever
come out every Tuesday these movie
retrospectives come out every Friday and
13 o'clock matinee three new movies in
theatres that comes out every Sunday so
check them all out if you haven't
already we will see you next time bye